merci à toi rien meilleur ami de l'homme
merci à toi vos chiens
tu es mon frère on sort
même si m
toi tu viens peu
toi qui fait fuir les blues merci à toi
viens pour toi mon ferme à venir
selon
waouh elle a créé de mes recherches
face à mon choisy sa brochette ça c'est
trop cher des proches avec eux merci qui
merci mon chien vous en êtes à votre
quatrième chanson sur les animaux oui
j'ai proposé pas mal de chansons sur les
animaux j'ai fait notamment une chanson
qui s'appelait de mastiquer merci mon
chat et qui était une très très belle
chanson et malheureusement on n'a pas
voulu faire passer dans l'émission parce
qu'il ya eu 14 ans le chant seront 14
émissions faites avec des gens du
chanteur qui avait des chats énormément
alors j'étais vous deviez changer de
changer d'idée j'ai essayé de faire une
chanson qui s'appelait merci qui merci
mon cheval avec un cheval je me joigne à
cheval ça m'a coûté une fortune lors
qu'elle coûtait l'émission band et
freine pas les sait qu'il va vous aider
pour savoir on ne défraie pas les gens
si vous faites une émission sur la chia
il faut que vous fournissiez cher sinon
si on rencontre quelqu'un qui a un chien
c'est parce qu'il l'a pas vraiment mais
vraiment c'est pas truqué avec montagny
elle pensait la farde pas moi j'aime
bien votre chien
on s'attendre
merci
yep je t'adore
même si
bon il ya merci mon frère méthode dans
le sikkim merci mon chien on découvre
votre attachement aux chiens je crois
que c'est l'histoire d'une longue amitié
c'est exact c'est plus qu'une amitié
c'est une espèce d'amour infini qui qui
unit l'homme le mrap en promo sapiens
m'assure aux chiens on pense de canon
sapiens c'est à dire que si vous voulez
les circonstances dans la vie où l'homme
cirque en spray scott il on arrive à des
contingences qui a exclu toute
exclusivité câline
je vous suis pas devenu sénateur le club
c'est moi c'est quoi ta tard
montmagny
merci à toi
bon jeu
toi qui mangent mais sognu merci à toi
mon chien au moins chers compagnons
merci actuellement chinois qui mangent
des oignons c'est assez curieux c'est
pas courant un chien je dis vous lance
des oignons s'est passé pour que ça
arrive parce qu'avant choix compagnon la
7e manche ce qui fait que ça rime pas
avec la merci à toi mon chien toi qui
fait fuir les ploucs
merci à toi mon chien oh toi mon cher
mabrouk mais c'est joli mais c'est
presque sarah ben en fait
merci à l'ancien temps qui fait fuir les
ploucs merci à mon chien autrement
sherbrooke
effectivement il s'appelle pas au bout
de ses peines va chômer brooks est le
nom du chien démission de jean pierre
hutin qui fait peur cette émission je
pensais me faire plaisir sur tunis que
ça passe d'ambition je me suis dit ça
lui fera plaisir
m
merci à toi
les oignons
partout de cette
oui
mais gentille
où